Shawn Davis is co-founder of the
Federalist which you should read if you
don't need a sort of great piece for The
Wall Street Journal describing the
collusion debacle is quote a
catastrophic media failure and even that
may be an understatement we're happy to
have him join us tonight Shawn as you
wrote this piece
you obviously collected what you've been
watching and thinking about for the past
couple of years how big was your
conclusion was the magnitude of the
screw-up here I think this is probably
the biggest most consequential screw-up
of the last 25 to 50 years it is
difficult to really comprehend or
overstate the damage that the media did
to the country to their own reputation
to the Constitution this was an absolute
catastrophe I I don't know any and I
know liberals who feel that way but I
don't know anybody running a media
organization on the Left who's willing
to admit it I mean just today there was
a piece in which Dean bouquet of the New
York Times and the editor of The
Washington Post and Jeff Zucker have
seen on all bragged about what a great
job they did how could they say that
well why wouldn't they they were given
Pulitzers they were showered with
adulation by their peers they were able
to Pat each other on the back and tell
them that they were heroes that they
were gonna bring down the next president
and hold him accountable there's no
incentive in the mainstream media for
them to have gotten this right all the
incentives were in the wrong direction
whether it was traffic or viewership or
just ideology there was no reason at all
for it for them to get this right so the
Muller report summary comes out Sunday
afternoon and the next day shows on CNN
and MSNBC drop by as much as 50% in
viewership just on the news doesn't that
kind of tell you everything about their
incentive to pretend that there is
collusion that there is a conspiracy
there audience goes away without it
absolutely and we saw the reaction was
like a children finding out the Tooth
Fairy isn't it real they're their bread
and butter in the age of Trump is to
ratchet up the hysteria to get people
completely freaked out so they feel like
they have to watch the news every day
and every
to figure out what's going on they did a
huge disservice to their audience and to
the country with their antics and their
conspiracy spreading over the last two
years it I mean it's hard to know what
comes next certainly in this environment
but I mean when the smoke clears and
Trump is gone or what you know whatever
happens in the next 10 years where do
you go for news will anyone ever believe
CNN assuming it still exists or the
Washington Post or the New York Times
ever again how could you write and
that's their problem is they didn't just
destroy their own reputations for all
the talk about how Donald Trump has
eroded and damaged our vital norms and
institutions it's the media themselves
who lended credence to his charge that
they were the fake news media it's the
media themselves who broadcast to
everyone you don't need to trust us
we're not trustworthy I don't know how
they come back from this it's totally
right if you don't want to be called a
liar stop lying I guess would be my
advice Sean Davis is great to see you
thank you for that terrific good to see
you thank you